tell me this as a director when did you
kind of come to the realization that
you might be able to play the gnarly old
guy
it's funny i didn't interview graham
you'll enjoy this because you're now the
gnarly old guy
oh yeah and so i was doing an interview
the other day
and they said you know you used to be in
all these movies like outside and
ocean's 11
and they go is this is this what you
want to now do with your career
i was like no i don't want to be the
only
old gnarly guy it's called aging there's
nothing i can do about it
i'll go back to 1998 i would
but the young actor playing the young
augustine ethan
ethan is it but ethan peck oh there he
is he's yeah
there he's on plays me as a young man
and
i'm directing and i'm casting and so
he's six foot three
great looking and i'm like you know i
can't cuss on this thing but i said
you know screw it i'm hiring that guy
but now we we can see how accurate he is
as in terms of being you at that age
because we've got a picture of
you at that age uh here you are
uh look at you oh that wasn't that age
you are a rat are you
are you young you're younger there older
22
look at the mullet you don't have that
mullet when you're 30.
it's a 22 year old mullet but here's the
thing here's the thing we can go further
back george because your father
your father recently he revealed this
picture of you
at 11. now if anyone at home is thinking
god
my children are so ugly uh
this is no this is really cheery because
this 11 year old
grew into george clooney
[Applause]
we didn't have a lot of cash and my mom
cut my hair and clearly
that's not her skill
she was in a hurry that day ray charles
could have cut my hair better